[dramatic music]
It's a breathtaking
moment for me.
NARRATOR: In the sands
of the necropolis,
Basem has made an
incredible discovery.
BASEM GEHAD: So what
we are looking here
is one fragment of
a mummy portrait
that is painted with the
wax, the encaustic technique.
NARRATOR: Greek
artists from Alexandria
traveled South through
Egypt along the Nile.
People commissioned
their portraits
from the artists, who painted
with hot beeswax onto wood.
The lifelike portraits
were unlike anything
in Egyptian art.
People hung their colorful
portraits in their homes.
When they died, the portrait
was put on their face
before they were
mummified in the hope
their spirit would
remember what they
looked like in the afterlife.
[dramatic music]
It's really a masterpiece.
NARRATOR: Despite
the layers of dust,
Basem can clearly make out the
face of the woman it depicts.
BASEM GEHAD: We can
realize all the detail--
the hairs, eyes, nose,
lips, and even the necklace,
the green necklace from emerald.
And the tunic, the Greek tunic,
which is painted in purple.
NARRATOR: It's a beautiful
portrait of a Greek woman who
lived and died here
at Philadelphia
around the time of Cleopatra
some 2,000 years ago.
Basem thinks tomb
robbers must have broken
the fragile painting
when they tried
to remove it from the grave.
BASEM GEHAD: When it's
broken into small fragments
or slides, for
them, it's useless.
They could not sold
it to the market.
So most probably, they
left it at the site.
For us, it's a treasure.
I can't see any kind
of object that could be
more beautiful than this face.
NARRATOR: It's a
great discovery,
everything Basem has hoped for.
BASEM GEHAD: The
aim of the mission--
we can say that
it's accomplished.
This single piece makes
our work here worth it.
Because it's-- in
itself, it's unique.
NARRATOR: It's
possible that Cleopatra
too would have been buried with
a lifelike portrait of herself.
We know very well
that ancient Egyptians
were very keen in keeping
the picture of the deceased.
It seems that the
tradition continued
during the Ptolemaic Period.
They kept the same
tradition, but they
did it their own way using a
new tradition of paintings.
And then they put these
wonderful, amazing, awesome
portraits on the face and then
they wrapped the whole mummy
in an Egyptian style.
NARRATOR: Basem's
discovery suggests
that even outside Alexandria,
the Greeks of her reign
followed Cleopatra's example
and embraced Egyptian customs.
And Cleopatra's respect
for the old ways
won her favor with
the Egyptians,
allowing her to rule
over a prosperous
multicultural empire.
[music playing]